i have this from today it's very
important story probably the most
important story that we have today this
is from today.com
they say there's a dangerous new trend
going viral on social media it's called
the milk crate challenge and it first
popped up on tiktok and is now making
the rounds to social platforms like
twitter and instagram experts warm the
unsafe trend coupled with the
overcrowding of u.s emergency rooms due
to cover 19 could be a disaster waiting
to happen
um the milk crate challenge calls for
stacking milk crates in the shape of a
pyramid and successfully walking up one
side and down the other um
sean anthony an orthopedic surgeon said
the milky challenge is very dangerous
we're seeing many orthopedic injuries as
a result injuries can include broken
wrists shoulder dislocations acl and
meniscus tears as well as
life-threatening conditions like spinal
cord injuries so the doctors are
speaking out they're saying this is very
dangerous but uh this is the this is the
trend it's it's very bad it's not funny
i don't approve of it at all
but let's just for educational purposes
we're gonna watch one of these and let's
see this guy trying the mill this is
what the milk again just for educational
reasons we play this
totally i want you to be educated on the
milk crate challenge i want you to know
what it looks like so that you know if
you're if your children
if your children are stacking milk
crates you know it's probably pretty
good oh and oh my gosh
oh you'll land it right on his back that
is a spinal cord injury it's not funny
at all though
um and uh i don't approve of it i'm
quite concerned but let's just watch one
more
again
purely for the sake of uh of education
so if you see your children doing this
then that is a big big red flag
you see that you see the milk crate
pyramid in your yard and your and your
your kids say oh we're just you know
we're making a pretty design no no no no
oh no oh my gosh
oh man
is that guy dead okay he's not dead
it is it's only
it's simply terrible it's not funny
there's not don't plea
please everyone do not try that
i kind of want to try it i do but i
won't
i want to try it if for no other reason
then how funny it would be for me to be
going to the emergency room
you know with 15 broken bones and i got
to call my wife and explain what
happened
hey babe i'm going to the emergency room
uh
i don't have time to get into details i
was climbing some milk crates i broke 15
bones
[Music]
anyway there it is so really really
concerning stuff
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends